I large I didn't talk until I was like
15 years old I was pretty much silent
which no one believes being kind to
people and listening to people tell you
about their families in their lives
people will think you're not funny
because of the way that you look my
favorite artists have always been the
ones that stick together with their
group that feeling of like waiting for
this pregnant woman to leave so I could
finish writing my like little weird
plays that I would write is when I say
oh I love doing this it felt like you
better get your own shows do it if
anyone should be doing it right it
should be me and that's makes sense and
I actually like that like I've never
been just like one like live for the
moment and who cares what happened like
c'est la vie like I was never that I was
highly organized I just want to be
skating since I'm 12 years old I've just
been like oh god I just wish I could be
one of those skinny girls never happened
I meet handsome men and cute in unusual
ways on television enough season my
character might get a pet puppy she's an
American actress comedian and writer
she's the creator and star of the Fox
sitcom the Mindy project she's also
known for her work on the NBC sitcom the
office
she's Mindy Kaling and here her top ten
rules for success it is very important
to be expressive and so much that no one
should ever be stopping you from saying
what you need to say or you should never
have that fear however I think as a
young person it's equally important if
not more important to be perceptive and
to be sensitive and I feel like we don't
talk about that a lot because we feel
like the only way to show that we're
empowered is by speaking in and I think
that you know when I was growing up I
really thought that what my parents
taught me it was a guy large I didn't
talk until I was like 15 years old I was
pretty much silent which no one believes
and it's because I just was like
listening and paying attention to what
everyone was saying and you know trying
to have a good social IQ which I think
helped me become a really would help me
later to become a writer and I think
that that is the the one biggest thing
is to really you know to listen to
others more than necessarily putting
such a premium on being able to say how
what you feel the best
I forgot is probably from Greg Daniels
and he's given me tons of good advice
but one piece of advice he gave me which
seems very simple with is very hard to
follow all the time is be kind which is
if you're in a room with kind of a bunch
of like sardonic East Coast educated
like kind of impatient writers it's very
hard to show kindness and I think that
especially graduating from comedy writer
to running a show where you're like I'm
a manager like I can be sued for like
Human Resources issues like that's not
something that I came into this doing
like it's like being kind to people and
listening to people tell you about their
families in their lives it's like I
think that was a very useful piece of
advice I came up with people who wanted
to so like I said the writers I work
with identify as feminists they want to
include women they are excited about the
voices of an Indian woman even if they
are white man the way that I am also
excited about female voices and my
writing staff and like I'm just a no
comedians I'm all sort of but it is it
is it is been challenging I think one of
the things that's been helpful to me is
that I try not to think that much about
the fact that I'm like in the American
so many people will look at me and be
like you're different than everyone else
but I can't sort of think about it I
can't like think about my legacy or
whatever because it stops me from being
productive and then it's a distraction
mm-hmm and I don't want to deny Who I am
because it's it's so important to me but
I can't rely on it right and that's just
been something that I think is so
important because people will try to
make you feel like Herman I've felt that
constantly people assuming I'm not funny
in New York coming up as a stand-up
Laird coming up and trying to do improv
and stuff people will think you're not
funny because of the way that you look
is you have to just be like I'm not
gonna like think in this in these terms
at all like I'm just gonna ignore it and
I think that's my advice to people is
like you can get so hung up and being
like am i the victim of the situation
maybe like I'm in charge of it and I'm
it's a I I think that's been why I've
been able to be successful is like my
singular crazy richer
Nixon like focus cool presidents pic he
was locust my favorite artists have
always been the ones that stick together
with their group you know whether it's
Christopher Guest and his actors who are
often in a lot he seems like a company
or Woody Allen using Dianne Wiest and
Mia Farrow and it also just makes the
quality of life so much better because
my hours are so long and if I can just
pack the scenes in the writers room with
my old friends first all things go
faster and second of all it's like you
get to transition from like work to
social life much more easily now that
said there in all of my original friends
at the office like make sure he went on
to creeper Club and Parks is very busy
all is running newsroom BJ has his
second book out and Gregg is you know
Gregg but it's great when they can just
kind of come in and do that also the
tone of the office is just great I know
that it's a mock documentary in our show
is very cinematic and right it's very
different but in terms of the types of
jokes we write if they're all that is
exactly the same I think I was a little
kid I had very very protective parents
who would not let me out a lot to do a
lot of stuff they didn't do any sports I
was not going to instruments we never
really traveled or anything I was just I
was just like told to study but my
parents worked study and read books and
so I think that so much of my childhood
was sitting at my mom as a doctor and
she'd have her office where she would
see patients and talk to them and then
they can exam room and then there was an
extra room that was for storage and for
phlebotomy which is like drawing Bloods
so cuz we like my mom didn't want to
leave me with like a nanny after school
I would take the bus to her office go to
this last room and then I'd sit there
with the typewriter and I'd either read
or write that was all I could do and
then if someone had to come in and get
their Bloods taken I would just get
shuffled out
and then a pregnant woman would just be
sitting there getting a blood drawn and
then like I'd kind of wait impatiently
and then she'd leave and then I come
back in and start writing again
so to the point where like they would
read what I was writing and I would
write these stories and I think that
that feeling of like waiting for this
pregnant woman to leave so I could
finish writing my like little weird
plays that I would write is when I say
oh I love doing this like and I can do
it without anybody else to entertain me
to have a successful pilot on network
television right now is so rare you must
have been over the moon
how did it happen what was the secret to
your success well I think that I had
been it is very rare and it's I was so
lucky and have had so many people
involved from all of our studio execs
and Beliveau Jharia and everyone at Fox
and Kevin Riley who had had a long
relationship with but Greg Daniels had a
writers room and season 2 of The Office
it was like she knew stupnitsky Lee
Eisenberg who then went on to start
trophy wife and write bad teacher BJ
Novak who's done a ton of amazing stuff
make sure who did person reckoned now
whatever so Paul Lieberstein is now sure
running the newsroom and does director
episode so of that group it's not that
weird to have your own show right so
that give that it it were very
competitive and sort of high achieving
people that like the season two writers
room so on it felt like you better get
your own show because everyone else is
doing which is a good atmosphere to be
in I think diversity has become like a
thing with this show the topic of you
know contention but I I'm more
interested in knowing how you feel about
that in terms of like having to address
it and justify your decisions has it
been you know it's so important to me so
I sit a lot of times when I talk about
it that I get really good like
passionate about it and I ultimately
take it as a compliment because I just
get held up to a higher standard because
there's a sense that if anyone should be
doing it right it should be me and
that's makes sense and I actually like
that about that I like that people have
a higher expectation to me than other
shows I think we can always be doing
better
and you know we sometimes what people
don't see behind the scenes is like we
want to get Kevin Hart on the show or
dule and they can't do it because I'm
scheduling and people don't know that
because we don't advertise it but um
it's I love our cast of things though
it's just so funny and so great I think
to dark-skinned women of color and as
series regulars in the show one of whom
is the lead is I feel really proud of
that and that's said it's like we are
always trying to do better do you have a
blueprint for your career not a blue
clean credit cleanse but an actual
blueprint yeah I've always been one of
those weird kids were like when I would
go to high school I would like make a
list of like all the things that I
wanted to do and then I kind of like
check them off like a serial murderer
like did I do this and do this and do
this and when I went to college I like
assessed what I thought was like cool to
accomplish and then I like checked it
off like I've never been just like one
like live for the moment and who cares
what happened like c'est la vie like I
was never that I was highly organized
and so I think when I was younger this
is one of the cooler things about my
life and I have to acknowledge it
sometimes because when I like get mad at
it being humid or whatever that I was I
am living my live stream like the job I
have now I had a plan up until now which
was to get my own television show that I
would create and so I have to start
thinking more unless I unless I die so I
could die I could die this week or
something would that be that would be
pretty dramatic and cool but I barring
that I have to make some more plants so
now I'm looking and I'm like oh I should
maybe have kids get married maybe that
sort of thing I should do that now what
I'm understanding and what I'm telling
stories is that you think you want one
thing your whole life for me my whole
life just like I just want to be skinny
since I'm 12 years old I've just been
like oh god I just wish I could be one
of the skinny girls never happened right
and I wish I had like thick beautiful
hair or anything else and for this
character what's been fun is she just
wanted to get married and now it's
happening and she's like I want more
yeah
is something that it's super relatable
and it's the one thing that seems no
matter who I meet because a woman that
seems very constant so I like telling
that story so even though I have no idea
why I was asked to speak here today I
prepared to speech very carefully the
way that any good Dartmouth educated
graduate would I drank a 40 of
Jagermeister then I called my dad to see
if he would get me out of it he's here
today he could not get me out of it so I
tried to hire a college freshman to
write it for me in exchange for a two
hundred dollar gift card to Newbury
Comics that didn't work out finally
seeing that I absolutely had to do this
and couldn't get out of it rolled up my
sleeves sat down at my computer and
tried to buy a commencement address off
of moving commencement speeches calm my
credit card was declined so I had to
write the thing myself and here we are
today there are many many distinguished
speakers who have spoken here today I am
sharing the stage with Preet Bharara US
Attorney for the Southern District of
New York we've heard what a great guy he
is in 2012 he was named by Time magazine
as one of the 100 most influential
people in the world which apparently
they're just giving out
according to time he is battle terrorism
as evidenced by his conviction of the
Time Square bomber he's crippled
international arms dealers drug
traffickers and dealt with financial
fraud clearly Harvard wanted you to see
the full range of what India can produce
here mr. Brar fights finance criminals
and terrorism
I meet handsome men and cute in unusual
ways on television and next season my
character might get a pet puppy so is
one more important than the other who
can say the real reason I am here is as
Connie said I am obsessed with justice
not so much with the law but with
justice actually in my mind law is that
pesky thing that often gets in the way
of justice I believe in the Clint
Eastwood School of the law an eye for an
eye I don't think so that solves nothing
you take my eye I take your life my
friend okay in a duel Aaron Burr style I
don't want your stupid eye for what my
eye collection you're dead okay
yes duels are the first thing that you
learn when you enter my graduate program
the Harvard School of vengeance
again that is not what I came here to
talk to you about that's for the
reception after we can talk about that
more the Harvard Law School crest which
you can see in front of you is um it has
the word Veritas which means truth in
Latin I know this because though I have
been known as Mindy my whole life my
first name is actually Vera which means
also means truth it's true it's actually
too boring to make that fact out and if
you look at the crest you'll notice that
under this hallowed word there are three
bunches of asparagus
because asparagus is the the tallest in
the proudest of the vegetables
the pillar of the vegetable kingdom and
it's it's like the lot okay that is um
that is not asparagus that is that it's
wheat which makes also not a ton of
sounds either okay well that was like
three pages of my speech nope okay that
was that's a call back to asparagus I
have this really funny run about
hollandaise you'll never get to hear
that you know this isn't going anywhere
I'm gonna move past trying to make sense
of your crust which makes no sense thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because OB nough asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Mindy's
top ten rules add the biggest impact on
you and why leave it in the comments and
I'll join the discussion thank you so
much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon